people just now being allowed to
re-enter their homes after they were
evacuated for hours from an apartment
complex near unlv metro police say a
suspicious device was found in a vacant
apartment near torrey pines in
charleston that's where we find madison
kimbrough live with the latest in this
investigation madison
it was an active scene here with metro
police and the las vegas fire and rescue
bomb squad on site for hours here at the
tides on charleston apartment complex
neighbors say they were waiting out in
their car since three this afternoon and
finally around 6 15 metro police took
down the crime scene tape and left the
area saying the device they found was
not hazardous police also say the
suspicious device was found in an empty
apartment complex building the same
complex that we're at right now you can
actually see it right over there as for
the damages that you can see a fire
broke out two weeks ago so it's not
related to today's incident all
residents are currently back inside
their apartments they are home and
they're happy that they are safe and
sound reporting live near torrey pines
and charleston madison kimbrough live
local now